wir kochen heute das perfekte Curry für
Sandra schön dass du da bist du bist der
erste Gast in diesem neuen Format und
ich habe dich gefragt wie Du am liebsten
dein curry ist oh am liebsten esse ich
mein gelbes Thai Curry mit vielen
Sojasprossen war richtig dünn
geschnittenen Karotten Brokkoli
paniertes Hähnchen
Koriander und ganz ganz bisschen scharf
und äh eine eher dickflüssige Konsistenz
und bitte ohne Zucchini Kartoffeln
Paprika ja das war schon ich kann so
viel sagen das unterscheidet sich auf
jeden Fall von dem was man findet wenn
man nach dem gelben Curry sucht du hast
diese Order ich denke mal es ist eine
Order oder weil du meintest gerade schon
oft können wir du hast es noch nie
selbst gekocht woher ist das Rezept
bestellst du das immer so die Sache ist
einfach dass ich mir so wenn du Curry
bestellt dann kannst du ja quasi nur das
Fleisch entscheiden was für eine
Fleischsorte du rein haben willst aber
ich [ __ ] mir die Sachen immer selber
raus so dass ich die so ich bekomme das
Gericht und kriegt mir z.B manchmal in
der Kartoffeln
auch die ganzen Erdnüsse pick ich mir
immer einzeln raus voll der Film ja aber
selber kochen ist auch voll der Film
selber kochen ist voll der Film ich habe
zum Glück schon alles vorbereitet alle
Einkäufe da die Zutaten seht ihr ich
habe ein zwei Sachen geholt zusätzlich
nur wenn du sie magst wir kochen ein
Curry und dazu machen wir Reis würde ich
sagen oder ganz einfach hast du schon
mal Reis gewaschen
so zwei drei Mal ist er nicht mehr Milch
waschen
kann ich dir das anvertrauen einfach an
der Spüle einfach ein zweimal auswaschen
ich werde in der Zwischenzeit schon mal
anfangen zu schnibbeln und greifen immer
ein zwei Schalotten Sandy wir sind
mitten im neuen Jahr angekommen das
stimmt hast du Vorsätze ähm nein hast du
Pläne von denen du erzählen kannst ja
ich glaube ich habe es öffentlich noch
gar nicht einfach hier droppen ich
eröffne tatsächlich ein Kiosk wie in
Köln
Brüsseler Platz Nähe kann ich euch jetzt
schon sagen ich weiß es wird sehr viel
Arbeit aber darauf freue ich mich sehr
sehr dolle endlich mal so man hat ja das
Ziel so das eigene Baby zu haben
irgendwie ne so er sei jetzt irgendwie
ein eigenes Unternehmen oder keine
Ahnung Merch oder
ein echtes Baby genau weil ich Single
bin und kein richtiges Baby erzeugen
kann leider momentan
ich finde es aber richtig cool also ich
werde auf jeden Fall auch mal da sein
wirst du dir vornehmen auch mehr zu
kochen in diesem Jahr weil die große
große Köchin oder ohne Witz ich versuche
es jedes Jahr und jede Woche äh gucke
ich einfach mal so rein wie viele flink
Bestellungen nicht machen wie viele
wollt Bestellungen ich mache und ich
könnte jedes mal kotzen deswegen nehme
ich jede Woche vor aber ja bin
letztendlich doch zu faul also ich koche
ja schon viel wegen der Videos aber
sonst bin ich auch sehr dazu geneigt zu
bestellen und bei mir ist auch so ein
Ding wenn ich so ein paar Videos gedreht
habe die Woche da dann will ich auch
nicht irgendwie mir was Großes selbst
kochen oder so dann koche ich so selten
mal was mit Lara aber irgendwie auch
nicht so häufig und wie läuft's an der
Reis waschfron
Alter ja ist okay ist doch kein Problem
hast du schon mal einen Reiskocher
benutzt super einfach du nimmst einfach
so eins zu ungefähr ein halb Reis und
Wasser
kaufen ne kannst du das so pi mal Daumen
ausgesucht aus dem Kopf so ungefähr und
jetzt du haust das Ding zu und ich
glaube man kriegt einfach auf Start okay
jetzt geht's los
selber entscheiden wie lang das brauchen
und so genau fertig und danach ist er
dann so Dampf drin bleibt der fünf sechs
Stunden fresh dauert 20 Minuten aber
wenn er halt fertig ist dann haben wir
gar keinen Stress mehr das ist gut und
den Rest müssen wir uns schon mal keine
Sorgen mehr machen die sind so deine
Skills mit dem Messer ähm
außergewöhnlich gut äh schlecht würde
ich sagen okay schneiden einfach die
Schalotten in so feine Weibchen ich
bereite dir die vor du hast schon besser
genau
so eingelegt ja das kenne ich das kenne
ich so wie so eingelegte Gurken so ja
man also man weiß ja dass ich sehr gerne
wodka-schutz trinke und Vanessa Saft
Kuska dass man quasi nach dem Wodka
short kein so Cola oder Wasser oder so
trinkt sondern man nimmt halt entweder
so eine eingelegte Gurke oder eingelegte
Tomate oder so eingelegte Mais ist krank
dass man sich so
ein eingelegten Mais hinterher aber
schmeckt so geil ich war schon immer
zwei Möhren Bio Möhren ne deshalb müssen
wir die nicht schälen du hast gesagt
ganz wichtig für dich diese feinen
möhrenstäbchen ne genau ja musst du
extra fein geschnitten sein ja die
Schalotten die sind jetzt schon
kann man nichts sagen
unglaublich diese Bretter das ist
einfach alles rein tun ja nächste
schnippelaufgabe mach mal eine
Knoblauchzehe auch in feine Scheibchen
das Besondere ist eigentlich okay
eigentlich passt das perfekt dass du
heute hier zu Gast bist bei der ersten
Folge von dem Format weil du warst ja
einer der wenigen Gäste der bei
persönlicher Koch auch richtig mit
angepackt hat weißt du es noch ich
meinte da auch noch so Sandra hilft mit
ich meine es geht darum dass ich dich
bekoche aber das Handy ist einfach zu
nett nicht die hilft dann einfach ganz
ehrlich sagen an alle Zuschauer ihr tut
mir leid aber wenn Max kocht das ist so
eine riesen Ehre wie kamst du überhaupt
Curry war das einfach so dein erster
Impuls oder ist es gerade so eine Sache
die du übelst gerne isst die Sache ist
einfach das ist so keine Ahnung das ist
so eine Mahlzeit die ist schön warm und
die ist auch echt günstig stell mich
hier aber auch an ich glaube es gibt
wirklich wesentlich bessere Techniken um
Möhren in Streifen zu schreiben aber ich
mache das jetzt einfach so ja so am
besten
so ja hier die wie heißen die dieses
Gerät noch mal hier
Knoblauch ja
fette Männer sehr gut wie schnell das
geht ja ich mag das gerade voll muss ich
sagen weil ich war schon ein bisschen
nervös vor der Aufnahme weil so ein
neues Format so mit Gästen kochen das
mache ich so selten und so oder habe ich
eigentlich noch gar nicht gemacht aber
bisher läuft alles bestens ich glaube
geschnippelt ist alles wir können jetzt
glaube ich anfangen zu kochen oder wir
bereiten noch das Hähnchen vorkommen wir
machen alles wir bereiten alles vor und
dann braten ja guck mal hier das Handy
wir haben hier zwei Sorten
Hühnchenfleisch einmal Hühnerbrust
kennst natürlich das hier meines
Erachtens ein Geheimtipp Hähnchen
Kotelett das sind Hähnchenschenkel aber
ohne Knochen das ist besonders saftig
und das hier ist vielleicht eher das was
es so normalerweise dazu gibt so deshalb
probieren ja okay wie ist das bei dir
wie kriegst du das da serviert ist das
so in Würfeln ist das so quasi so
scheiden die Scheiben sind quasi so ist
es im ganzen frittiert und dann hat man
so eine Schnittkante oder sind die
einzelnen Teile extra frittiert also
sind die komplett in Panade geschlossen
oder sieht man da so quasi dass es
auseinander geschnitten wurde danach
also Frittieren wir quasi das ganze Ding
und schneiden es danach auseinander sehr
gut ich muss mal sagen selbst gekochtes
Essen schmeckt immer besser ja ist
einfach so ich bin auch echt gespannt
wie das heute wird ne Sandy oh du gehst
schon zu Dienste weißt du noch wie weißt
du noch wie eine panierstraße
funktioniert ähm ja erst das Ei dann das
Mehl dann äh das gebrüse oder
Brösel wie nennt man das denn ähm
es gibt nicht genug krank oder beim
Frittieren dass du mich auch ausgelacht
bei persönlicherweise auf Crunch gesagt
habe
okay Max krass auch wichtig danach alles
salzen und pfeffern also jeden Teil der
panierstraße Salz und pfeffern
nach der absolute so
geil wie du die Mühle immer wieder so
zurückdrehst
ja alles mein Pfeffer hat auch das Mehl
das ist wirklich so ein Trick damit
alles Geschmack hat muss man auch alles
würzen also Panade Soße wirklich mein
Ziel ist nichts Geringeres als dass du
so am Ende sagst boah das ist krass
lecker okay und ich glaube das schaffen
wir das schaffen wir wirklich wir gehen
jetzt mal unser Hähnchen hier hinein
genau
eine trockene und eine nasse Hand bei
der panierstraße weil jetzt z.B die Hand
ist meine trocknen jetzt gebe ich das in
die panierstraße das ist dann meine Nase
an damit das von allen Seiten schön
benetzt ist damit jetzt hier drüben
unser pengummi besser hält sobald das da
drin ist sehe schon wieder die andere
Hand so sieht das Ganze aus wenn es
fertig ist von allen Seiten paniert dann
können wir zur Seite legen ich würde
sagen das machen wir einfach mal schnell
mit allen weil danach können wir auch
anfangen zu kaufen
okay dann fangen wir mal an zu kochen
das Handy ich würde sagen wir müssen
eine Sache auf jeden Fall
berücksichtigen wenn man asiatisch kocht
dann nicht so alt bekannt mit Olivenöl
sondern mit Kokosöl machen wir das Heute
kannst erst einmal geben das ist diese
das kleine Glas da vorne ach so
später noch wir geben einfach mal ein
bisschen Kokosöl in die Pfanne hinein
richtig gesund und ich glaube das ist
auch gut um zu bräunen
oder
Doro hatte immer so ein so eine Flasche
äh Kokosöl dabei also so ein Glas das
wird ja in der Sonne Temperaturen
flüssig und hat sich damit immer
eingeschmissen wollen
möchtest du einmal die Schalotten
hineingeben war doch noch nicht heiß
genug wir haben gerade die ganze Zeit
überlegt ob die Fahne heiß genug ja
einfach selbst die die Geräusche macht
direkt an super boah riech mal bitte
wenn man das riecht dann weiß man dass
man das hier braucht um es wirklich
authentisch zu machen weil ohne diese
passte riecht einfach genauso wie wenn
du so also viel intensiver als wenn du
so eine bestellbox aufmachen auf jeden
Fall jetzt drei Esslöffel von unserer
Paste mit in die Pfanne und jetzt musst
du das die ganze Zeit so mit Patienten
quasi so ein bisschen ja aber mach dir
keinen Stress Nummer zwei du hast gesagt
du hättest es gerne nicht so scharf ne
genau deshalb ist das gelbe passt auch
die beste Wahl grün ist am schärfsten
dann rot und gelb ist glaube ich so
Milch ich wusste gar nicht dass es so
habe ich mich nicht drauf fest kannst du
den Knoblauch dazugeben geil Alter ich
freue mich richtig jetzt gehen wir ein
Stückchen von unserer Kokosmilch drauf
wir haben jetzt äh ein Liter ich glaube
insgesamt benutzen wir vielleicht die
Hälfte erstmal aber nur ein kleines
Stückchen kannst du bewegen ja jetzt zu
Beginn geht so darum dass du ein
bisschen aufzulösen und so eine kleine
Paste entstehen zu lassen
[Musik]
unglaublich viel Zeit Stress Alter gehen
wir noch ein bisschen was drauf
das ist so leicht ne alles war ja jetzt
nur so mit viel Zeit viel Gequatsche das
Vorbereiten aber an und für sich das
eigentliche Gericht ist super easy alles
was wir jetzt machen ist alles
reinwerfen fangen wir mal an von links
fangen als erstes mal den zuckermeister
dazu zack aber dazugeben Brokkoli dazu
zack Karotten dazu
jetzt gehen wir noch ein bisschen
Kokosmilch dran und da Links haben wir
Gemüsebrühe oh ich dachte das ist unser
frisch gefressen
ein bisschen älter davon schüttest du
jetzt einfach auch noch mal ein bisschen
was drauf also 100 ml locker können ja
immer noch nachschütten können auch
nichts raus jetzt vermengen wir das
ganze einfach und lassen es quasi darin
köcheln also alles gab da drin am Ende
gehen wir noch die Bohnen dazu dann
haben wir unser Curry das ist voll
bescheuert aber so leicht ist das
natürlich heute bisschen wie so ein
Vater weil du mir alles erklärst nicht
für mich super
toll die Soße köchelt jetzt etwas schon
10 Minuten und mir ist aufgefallen
Brokkoli und Gemüse sind generell schon
da wo ich sie haben will aber es ist
noch zu flüssig deshalb werde ich noch
weiter eindicken und hole davor erstmal
das Gemüse raus so dass das quasi nicht
weitergeht aber noch weiter ein köcheln
kann
ein bisschen Zucker dran ich würde da
gar nicht mal dran sparen weil ich
glaube das was man so aus Restaurants
kennt ist häufig schon so gut gesüßt ne
wir wollen ja das ist ja das was wir
abbilden wollen und eine weitere Zutat
die nicht fehlen darf ein bisschen
Fischsoße das riecht so nach Asia
Supermarkt finde ich aber es riecht auch
rein hoffentlich mache ich jetzt gar
nicht den Geschmack für dich kaputt ich
bin wirklich aufgeregt dass es ja am
Ende auch gut schmeckt hier drüben wird
das Öl heiß zum Frittieren probieren wir
noch mal kleinen Teelöffel du darfst
leider noch nicht probieren ich bestelle
nämlich jetzt einfach beim Teil
Restaurant wow das war ein riesen
Unterschied hat gerade auch schon
probiert das ist wirklich ein riesen
Unterschied gemacht
das hat uns wirklich gerade das hat uns
wirklich gerade noch mal so viel mehr
zum
70% sind wir mindestens bei 95 richtig
geil
[Musik]
ich hoffe dass es Dir nicht zu scharf
ist okay wir fangen an nehmen uns ein
bisschen Hühnchen und legen das vorm
Körper weg ins Fett hinein fängt an zu
blubbern nicht zu viele auf einmal in
den Topf und es ist gar nicht so
besorgniserregend wie man vielleicht
denken unser chicken hat die perfekte
Farbe des goldbraun das heißt jetzt muss
nur noch angerichtet werden das machen
wir und dann sehen wir uns endlich zum
Essen
[Musik]
endlich ist es soweit Sandy vor uns
steht hoffentlich dass für dich perfekte
gelbe Curry was sagst du
ich hatte noch nie so ein hübsches Curry
aus so mit dem Reis und so sieht schon
echt heftig aus dann auch noch sein ich
bin aufgeregt wie gut es dir schmecken
wird sollen wir einfach probieren komm
ist einfach so wie du Lust drauf hast
wir wollen das gar nicht überbewerten
gar nicht so riesig machen boah das
Hähnchen habe ich so Lust drauf ne das
sieht so gut aussehen
Currysoße schon mal für gut befunden ich
finde so Currysauce mit Reis ist auch
wichtig und das noch mal so abzumildern
boah mit Reis kommt das so gefährlich
alter Schwede ich bin sprachlos das
schmeckt das schmeckt noch intensiver
als man das so kennt ne das ist so
richtig das knallt
wow was hast du für Schärfe genau
perfekt ja
schicken probiert mache ich jetzt ich
nehme mal so ein bisschen schicken ein
bisschen Gemüse ein bisschen Reis
einfach alles auf einen Löffel ich muss
wirklich sagen ich bin sehr zufrieden
verstehst du jetzt Kotelett Hähnchen
Kotelett das ist ja so saftig
Alter was ich finde auch die
Zusammenstellung von Gemüse richtig geil
alles an Gemüse was da drin ist ist
richtig gut boah Maxi muss sagen das ist
sogar noch perfekter als das Curry was
zu mir so sonst zusammenfische ja heftig
das ist richtig krass
das hat so viel Spaß gemacht danke danke
dass du bei der ersten
wir müssen uns dann zusammen gemacht
aussieht danke fürs zuschauen
hoffentlich gefällt euch das Format
schreibt mir in die Kommentare bei wem
vielleicht bekannt ist dass er so eine
spezielle order hat so wie Monte doppelt
Käse doppelt Mais auf Pizza das sind so
die Sachen auf die wir in diesem Format
achten wollen das haben wir uns glaube
ich verdient und schaut bei seiner
vorbei ist verlinkt bis zum nächsten Mal
ciao ciao
heftig halleluja